we've talked a lot about marketing goals
throughout the course and these goals
are really important but they're not
worth anything if all you do is mention
them in a slide you need a way to follow
them and to ensure you're on track with
meeting your goals you have to be honest
and find the most accurate metrics to
measure these goals you're looking for
something that is clear and that will
help you to evaluate your progress think
about your car - word the fuel gauge
indicator turns on the light to transfer
the message no more gas soon enough you
won't be able to keep driving you need
metrics that are so clear and relevant
to your goal that every event tells you
something about the health of your
business
your metrics must be measured correctly
you don't want inaccurate or incomplete
data this could lead you down the wrong
path it has to be simple if it's too
complex to explain how it's related to
your business and marketing then there's
something wrong let's look at our goals
for abarkment that we created and listen
to